[Applaudissements]
bon
ça j'adore ça vous aimez ah bon jamais
dans ses très bons oui c'est un peu ça
peut ramener un peu de paillettes pour
des bagues des pailladins
prononce aujourd'hui oui j'ai du gros
dos qu'est-ce qui se passe vous savez
chaque semaine on commence avec bah ça
crosby seconde hinse a ses forces et
former la négoce est parti en vacances
non non c'est pas nikos c'est jean-luc
salut
tu as landais ont fait jean luc
reichmann mais quand il est étonné quand
il est étonné alors fait d'accord je
suis anti syrienne est à candidatures du
fonction attention bienvenue dans les
douze coups à 2008 ou après tout va bien
salah le public
le soleil
le soleil bienvenu je suis avec roger
bonjour j'ai
alors vous avez dit anecdotique c'est
tous parce que je suis boulanger
du port
entre autres de la baguette de
tu me réveille chez tous et pour aller
faire le point parce que c'est vrai que
les premiers clients arrivent très tôt
je me réveille à 3h30 à 3h30
et en fait je marie quatre heures mais
en 3 est en fait un jour j'avais mis mon
réveil à 3h30 mais de l'après midi
toujours possible mais c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et oui tous connu une autre prochain
candidat nous vient de clermont ferrand
oui oui tout va bien oui c'est vrai que
je suis avec donc christophe salengro
surf bonjour vous avez 35 ans oui sauf
raconté ou ce qui s'est passé avec votre
ex alors avec mon ex est très sain
j'étais avec une jeune fille voilà
pendant quelques années que sa
fille est en fait un jour elle me dit
allons restons au restaurant oui du coup
si l'onu donné au bond l adorer les
restaurants asiatiques asiatiques et là
on embrasse les nems
[Applaudissements]
oui je me demande à patates impérial et
qu'est ce qui m'amène qu'est-ce qui vous
aime mais a pâti de fou mais c'était
[Applaudissements]
donc
ses amis dans le métier
tu vois que ça me fait du bien oui le
soleil brille
après 50 minutes inside découvrit les
douze coups de baba
pour l'accueil depuis notre premier
candidat c'est un berbère et nous vient
tout droit
c'est un coup de maître cyril ne tient
plus ses chroniqueurs n'est que vers
l'avant ciani alors moi j'aimerais bien
revivre et je peux parler
ta grand mère ta
[Applaudissements]
question il sur le plateau aux fétiches
le but jour il fait chaud on dirait
qu'on est dans le cible de leurs mots
justes possibles cyril serait-il en vrai
une folle et j'ai l'impression que jai
deja général où tu sens fatigué j'ai mal
à la tête j'ai été ton dur ce genre
attention attention ou celui qui bât
blesse ils veulent tous les dimanches où
magali bern animera tpm que des manches
les mots politiquement et sam est un
rendez vous politique et sur des
bases tout de suite la question du coup
par coup
c'est qu'il va jouer avec moi pas d'âme
giguère jouer au paddle avec cyril ainsi
yannick noah moteur ou l'autre noah
zidane mais arrête c'est sûr ça ça vient
de tomber je peux plus zinédine zidane
mais qui meurent fumer sur le cul cul de
sueur et
il a vu la fumée sur mon île c'est drôle
ça drôle jeanne d'arc franchement
j'adore mais tu disais que ça aurait dû
la double tout j'ai l'idée c'est bruno
face à google c'est à dire qu'il ya les
chroniqueurs ils ont google je lui
posais une question si vous trouvez la
réponse avant lui il perd l'argent
[Musique]
si matthew d'aimer mes idées merci on va
le faire ça ah oui c'est à yakassé live
absolument le faire par exemple prévu
d'animer d'animer les bras c'est moi
c'est moi c'est moi c'est moins crédible
car c'est moi c'est moi non
répond moi dites moi une phrase qui
pourrait que vous seriez la bonne
personne pour l'animer sachez le bad
dans les vieux d'abord non mais il n'y a
pas de question et une meilleure pour
les jeux mathieu je suis mûr tout court
non c'est la jeunesse cyril voilà bien
des films alors qu'elle animait à vous
affectionnez thanvillé nuit bon d'accord
merci mes péchés delphine camp non mais
mais moi je vous dis arrêtez pour
dénoncer mais mathieu aussi maintenant
mais c'est plus possible et audrey et
moi aussi on apprend une femme j'ai dit
mais pas tout de suite mais qui veut qui
veut moi moi je veux à delphine aussi
cbl rien dit c'est sérieux c'est la
dilapider pourquoi désormais l'envié de
faire oui mais là bas ce sera telle
fille
pourquoi parce que celle qui sait c'est
je pense qu'il faut faut de la douceur
ouais ouais je suis double mission ouais
bah merci bon je suis
doublej
il a dit aux patrons de manèges et faire
de la télé lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans un instant quand tu auras plus de
carrière on n'en parlera
pas
vous savez qu autour de la table ou
chroniqueurs étaient des gros faux culs
we should sanaa
parce qu'il ya quelques jours vous avez
émis l'idée d'un nouveautés pmp le
dimanche oui que donc la nouveauté pmp
dans la semaine donc c'est une très
bonne idée autour de la table ils
étaient tous là en train de cirer les
pompes mais figurez vous que je suis
d'indiquer je me suis faufilé en loge
c'est un retour des caméras de rien je
vais les voir ils pensent pas pareil là
je suis en plein travail
2 ça va partir en sucette sur la tête de
tôtes les chéris donc je vous le dis on
aura peut-être un touche pas à mon poste
de plus on est en train de réfléchir
avec la direction de la chaîne vous
pensez que ces bonnes idées vraiment moi
je pense que ça peut faire même des
meilleur score qu'en semaine
ces problèmes des gens m'ont fait
perdre est génial et en plus le dimanche
il ya de l'actualité politique et sur
l'art de dimanche donc formidable
percée dans le direct de 19h à 21h
accord extrêmement fort positionnement
idéal franchement vous deviez faire
vraiment penser que c'est une bonne idée
à l'afrique est un professionnel de la
télé on voit ce qu'est ce que les goûts
devient le dimanche soir c'était disons
sur
près de 6 et 6 3 il y présente
tu viendrais en chroniqueur
way the body shop in non alors voyons ça
ne me déçoit pas du tout juste comme je
vous le dis le projet est en train de
prendre forme ou la petite info médias
bien sûr tout ce que vous avez pu voir
dans le magnéto vous ne les verrez pas
le ballon va sans dire mulliez où vous
serez là bien entendu j'ai vraiment
voilà isabelle bien entendu journal si
vous êtes choqués audrey version grand
place à lille c'est non et de leur
vocation sociale ou le dimanche c'est
que vous vous reposiez parce que vous
travaillez comme un chien tout avant
tout le monde les autres qu'on dit du
mal je serais très heureux de l'animé je
ferai ça moi bien vous bien sûr il
serait très heureux de l'animé vont vous
reposiez reposer vos dimensions
c'est cette année il ya un chroniqueur
qui fait un très beau début de saison
que qu'on aime tout ce chroniqueur qui
est très aimé d'ailleurs par mathieu
masseau chroniqueur c'est mathieu de
leur banc matthieu delormeau qui en ce
moment alors il va très bien mais il a
des petits soucis de coeur il n'arrive
pas à trouver l'amour et du coup il
saute sur tout ce qui bouge alors
s'ériger un petit conseil faites
attention à votre cul ça va vous
recevoir c'est bon
[Musique]
bonjour comment ça va ça mon chéri
du coin c'est
marcel aymé moi çà mau shihri merci
d'être l'intérieur
[Musique]
ce tome est révélateur de mais leur
effet que jany des réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
vous donner votre numéro un tabac il me
le demander
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme j'ai pas de travail j'ai pas de
mec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
steve-o mesdames et messieurs
aujourd'hui me dit de fonds tony prend
chokolo mise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec le pompier la meilleure phrase
c'est quand même un million d'hommes mur
d'eau et des beaux gosses
le gars des intempéries
c'est d'ailleurs tout et on verra les
intempéries j'étais en contact
d'ailleurs avec comptage lui au
téléphone hier quentin voilà ça c'est
toujours compliqué pour eux je vais
essayer de l'avoir cette semaine une
association qui s'est monté on va
essayer de les aider également mais
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué mais
c'est vrai qu'il était extrêmement beau
gosse extrêmement sympathique qu'il n'y
avait aucune moquerie dans ma phrase il
le mec des intempéries mais ça va bien
sûr et où je vois la mémé tu es beau
grâce et je lui souhaite
mieux je serais ravi d'aller à marseille
pour apporter mon soutien
[Rires]
et quand un super gars qui aimait va
tuer
et vous recevez gamesa qu'ils ont qu'on
a reçue à thébaux munitions c'est aussi
une grande victoire et 5 millions
d'euros c'est mon style oui quand même
pas ses moyens la confiance est
[Applaudissements]
jamais si c'est ça son problème je me
venge son problème c'est son problème
non mais ce joli match et une belge chez
conforama
je pouvais pas repartir sans évoquer
l'histoire d'amour que dix jeux l'idylle
entre gens mais cia et guillaume genton
alors chaque semaine on voit que les
deux places des mots qui sont très potes
etc mais cette semaine il ya eu de l'eau
dans le gaz cette semaine il ya eu des
petites tensions sur ce plateau entre
jean messia et guillaume genton
rien ne va plus entre carla tout à
l'heure en plus un jeu sérieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
oui en championnat
mais ce que je comptais pas pourquoi
tu vois pas ce que j'ai fait
alors bien sûr
quand il était composé à partir en fumée
transformer le temps ralentit contre
ces choses
bientôt je vais doubler bâtard
c'est tendu
manches ont été courues hamida
endroit
oui
bien tranquille nantais proposent
vêtements chauds
et
[Musique]
moi juste pétition il n'y a que des ou
danser et sans rigoler non mais vous
vous devez tension c'est pas cette
techno évidemment appelé c'est peut-être
ma page avait cédé
[Rires]
ses parts dans une émission de dialogue
jeudi mais
il faut juste qu'ils baissent les yeux
c'est tout non non non discutable en
quoi je sais
pas mais qu'est ce qui se passe chez
passer cette robe noire verbard vous ne
vous êtes pas autant plus vous avez beau
jeu ressemble bon je t'aime bien
tranquille quand même ça va merci
majorité
serait pas libéré non c'est vrai j'aime
bien mais je suis en tout cas vous êtes
vraiment du pôle et ouais ça soit au
niveau du look
vraiment fini toujours par savoir
monsieur le jour quand il s'appelle
j'avais regardé mais qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent regardent ils s'appellent tous
les deux alors qu'ils sont à 50 cm
maintenant c'est l'explication
[Rires]
je sais qu'en achetant mère d'isabelle
c'est quand tu termines et merci rideau
merci sociale
[Applaudissements]